- - Madeleine Blais-Morin
SéSébastien Bovet bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir Alexis.
- - Retour ça se forcément il ft
paparler de vaccinations
obobligatoires, y aura aussi
d'd'autres thématiques aura 13
miminutes au créneau pour en
didiscuter. Obligatoires d'abor.
IlIl y a les fédéraux et aussi
popour voyager à laisser du pay,
lala date butoir approche.
CoCommençons par les
fofonctionnaires fédéraux gros
dodossier de Monsieur Trudeau
ququ'il a traîné en cours de
cacampagne électorale. Comment a
s's'est passé pollue cette
sesemaine? Est-ce que ça passe
bibien?
- - Évidemment il y a des gens i
sosont contre des gens qui
réréagissent négativement cette
anannonce qui est majeure quandn
paparle d'obliger la vaccination
dede tous les fonctionnaires
féfédéraux même ceux qui
trtravaillent chez eux, il n'y a
papas beaucoup de compromis. On
ututilise la méthode forte. Tous
leles voyageurs qui empruntent e
trtrain ou l'avion vont être
totouché. Ça fait beaucoup de
momonde donc beaucoup de
mémécontents potentiels. Magicin
TrTrudeau n'avait pas le choix
paparce qu'il a fait campagne l-
dedessus, c'était devenu un enju
popolitique pour lui et après ça
fafait reprocher d'avoir déclené
leles actions. On lui aurait
rereproché davantage de ne pas
memettre en une des principales
prpromesses de sa campagne
élélectorale. Je vous dirai que
j'j'ai l'impression que l'équipe
TrTrudeau sans que la population
etet de son bras, sans que la
popopulation qui a été vaccinée,
ququi est vaccinée commence à
avavoir une patience qui s'effre
papar rapport à nos vaccinées.
AuAujourd'hui on a eu un point e
prpresse la Santé publique qui
nonous montrait les prévisions
popour les prochaines semaines a
prprochaine avait quand même des
dodonnées frappantes qui dit: cz
leles noms vaccinés on on a 10
fofois plus de sens d'attraper a
cocopie que chez les personnes
plpleinement vaccinées. En fait
leles nouveaux cas sont 10 fois
plplus nombreux chez les noms
vavaccinés que cela pleinement
vavacciné. Quand on parle des
hohospitaliers sont peu multipls
etet pas 36 donc 30 fois plus
d'd'hospitalisation sur les noms
vavaccinés que chez les personns
plpleinement vaccinées.  : Le
gogouvernement disait ça regardr
leles cas en l'heureux maxillaie
nonos vaccinées, et doivent-ells
papas aussi. C'est un message ou
lele gouvernement essaie de
momontrer l'exempleé
- - Sébastien votre regard là-
dedessus.
- - C'est un peu le même
raraisonnement que François
LeLegault a appliqué au Québec.a
vavaste majorité qui fait vaccir
nene doive pas subit les
coconséquences de ce qui ne se
fofont pas vaccinés. Monsieur
TrTrudeau aborde la question
didisant : les gens ont répondu
prprésent à l'appel de la
vavaccination maintenance qui va
memettre une pression sur le
réréseau de la santé s'il y a
prpression sur les noms vaccinés
avavec l'acide la Santé publique
cacanadienne, il faut agir il ft
réréduire le plus possible risqe
quque notre réseau de santé
s's'écroule. Il faut cibler les
nonoms vaccinés et la l'opinion
pupublique derrière lui sans aun
dodoute.
- - Les syndicats allés selon
nanationale ça enverra bien c'et
unune forme de passeport vaccine
papancanadienne, ça pourrait
fafaciliter les choses. Passons
mamaintenant au Québec Sébastien
lele réseau de la santé sa date
bubutoir qui approche, Monsieur
DuDubé qui maintient la pression
etet envoie un signal très clair
auaux fédérations
prprofessionnelles. Dans ce
dodossier comment évaluez-vous a
réréception du message?
- - La loge faite Taccone au Joe
MoMorrison jour dans le fond das
unune semaine. Le ministre Dubé
auaugmente la pression. Ça
cocommençait par vous de vous ft
vavacciner d'ici le 15 octobre.
DeDepuis le début la semaine ne
sosont pas vaccinés se
reretrouvent... vous ne serez
pepeut-être pas assuré si vous
n'n'allez pas au travail si vous
êêtes suspendu sans solde. Vous
dedevriez prendre des discussios
popour vos dispositions pour
memettre avocat d'accès aussi ax
ununiformes. Et là depuis hier e
nonouvel avertissement votre ore
prprofessionnel pour les
ininfirmières et les infirmiersl
y y a les inhalothérapeutes par
exexemple pourrait suspendre voe
drdroit de travailler. Si vous
n'n'êtes pas vacciné le 15 octoe
etet que vous allez travailler
popour une entreprise privée, yn
a a de grandes entreprises qui t
dedes infirmières à charge, dans
seses deux fois parce que votre
pepermis de pratique pour être
sususpendu. Les messages envoyés
papar Dubé c'est que on va mette
dudur. Ce sera tolérance zéro e-
cece que jeudi prochain à 14 15
heheures, irradier Belambra attd
popour ceux qui ont la première
dodose? Y en a qui pense que ce
sesera possible. J'en ai aucun
sisignal mais ce qui pense que
auaurait des assouplissements en
totout cas qu'il envoie pour
l'l'instant c'est pas de tolérae
asassouplissements.
- - Il y a un élément qui envoie
dedes cours à la fois au travaià
QuQuébec ce sont les exemptions
rereligieuses évoquées par Otta.
MaMadeleine précision de quoi il
s's'agit?
- - Le ministre a dit que ce sot
rerestreint est-ce que je
cocomprends de ce que j'ai eu
GoGouveia fédéral c'est que le
gogouvernement voudrait se
prprémunir contre d'éventuelles
cocontestations en vertu de la
chcharte canadienne des droits t
lilibertés. Le gouvernement avat
l'l'impression que ça toucherait
trtrès peu d'individus parce que
leles grandes religions ne sont
papas opposées à la obligatoires
etet à la vaccination tout cour.
LaLa le gouvernement l'impressin
ququ'il a de meilleures chancese
prpréserver sa politique très
lalarge s'il y a des présomptios
rerestreintes en vertu des drois
cacanadiens.
- - Pas d'exemptions religieuses
lele mini Dubé a dit en fait une
afaffaire de santé publique. Doc
lala Santé publique produit la
liliberté religieuse, appeler ça
cocomme ça. Donc ce ne sera pasn
momotif ne pas être vacciné.
- - Parlons du racisme systémiqe
ququi a été au coeur de la pour
MoMonsieur Legault qui a ajusté
soson message ou tonton à tout e
momoins6
- - il ne pouvait pas garder le
toton de la semaine dernière. En
paparlant du racisme systémique
MoMonsieur Legault reste campé r
sasa position les nations
auautochtones restent campées sr
lele position en disant il y ena
vovous d devriez agir la à des
popoints de convergence, c'est e
vovoir que François Legault ne
chchange pas d'avis ne changerot
papas d'avis. On peut arrêter de
totourner en rond et essaie
d'd'avancer améliorer les cautis
dede vie des autochtones un peue
réréparation un peu de
réréconciliation aussi parce que
susur le racisme systémique
pepersonne va bouger.
- - On verra s'il n'y aura pas e
foformule si toi mitoyenne qui
seseras adoptée discrimination
sysystémique.
- - Je salue Raphaël Jacob qui
sasalua votre sagesse mais je la
sasalue moi-même parce que en
efeffet il y a des moyens de
momoyens et des fois quand on vt
cocontourner une difficulté
trtrouvée de nouvelles voies por
ararriver au même but peut-êtren
ututilisant un vocable différen.
- - Madeleine ce débat sémantiqe
didiront certains, ce débat sura
dédéfinition n'est nécessairemet
papas fait à Ottawa. Monsieur
TrTrudeau ! développait ou
épépiloguer sur une définition
prprécise?
- - À n'est pas tombé dans une
dédébat de réconciliation. Ce qi
s's'est passé que Justin Trudeau
s's'est occulté auprès de ces
chchefs de la région de camelot
enencore pour avoir passé la toe
prpremière journée vérité et
réréconciliation journée décréte
papar lui-même sur une plage à
ToTofino. Là tu Trudeau n'avait
papas beaucoup de bien à lancer
vevers Québec en termes de
réréconciliation. Quant aux pase
prprésence ou non à une journéee
réréconciliation, on ne parle ps
d'd'actions concrètes mais à peu
prprès tout le monde s'entendait
popour dit que Trudeau a manqué
unune occasion de participer à
cecette réconciliation la. Je me
didiras aussi que Trudeau devrat
sese questionner sur son jugemet
mamais aussi sur le jugement de
soson entourage. Son entourage
dedevrait servir de garde-fou ne
l'l'a pas prévenu que c'était ue
mamauvaise idée de commencer ses
vavacances cette journée-là, on
n'n'en parlerait plus une journe
plplus tard s'il avait commencé
jojournée plus tard la semaine
dedernière.
- - Un tour rapide sur ?
coconservateur que retenez-vouse
sasa.
- - On suivait celui du parti
coconservateur de plus près
papassons une ce qu'il advenait
ErErin O'Toole. Il a passé un
prpremier test mais on parle pls
dede recentrage. Les gens sont
mamalades pas à. Un des constats
fafaits derrière les portes clos
àà l'importance de parler, de
cocommuniquer adéquatement avec
leles immigrants, les nouveaux
ararrivants. On a dit pas en cas
ToToronto il arrive environ 150
00000 nouveaux arrivants par
anannée. Si le parti conservater
n'n'est pas capable de connecter
avavec eux adéquatement, le pari
coconservateur va s'éloigner de
plplus en plus de faire des gai.
SiSi important à Toronto et dans
lala banlieue de Toronto. Le
prpremier ministre D'Almeida étt
paparvenu lui à faire cette
dédémarche de connexion avec
leles nouveaux arrivants et on
didirait que ça c'est perduré
dedepuis. C'est un constat du
tetemps je vous parlais du NPD
dadans un instant.
- - Oui ça se corse allez-y
rarapidement Sébastien je vous
réréponds pas du toc.
- - On pense que Monsieur autoré
enen probation. En même temps ne
sosont pas une forte pression de
l'l'extérieur. J'ai noté qu'il
paparle d'une de déclenchement s
élélections de 18 mois et lui ft
ququ'il martèlece point à Cécila
dede du moi les conservateurs
n'n'ont pas payé la lutte de des
élélections.
- - A beaucoup fait jaser
auaujourd'hui on va en parler
auaujourd'hui.
- - Bonjour tout le monde. Bonjr
totout le monde. Bonjour tout le
momonde. . bonjour tout le monde
bobonjour tout le monde.
- - Le fameux bonjour tout le
momonde à répétition de François
LeLegault, c'était son entrée en
scscène ces plafonds se trouvent
d'd'autres politiciens meeting
DoDominique Anglade. Que retene-
vovous de cette stratégie
popolitique?
- - Avoir l'air cool face à cete
nonouvelle génération. On verra
papas danser.
- - Il faut comprendre les causs
dede toc. Ce sont des codes et
popour que ça fonctionne faut qe
çaça atteigne le publique cible.
IlIl va falloir qu'il y ait une
ststratégie derrière ça. Jagmeet
SiSingh la contrôle bien mais
enencore une fois il y a 800 et
404000 personnes qui se meeting,
cece n'est pas nécessairement
trtransformé en vote. Il y a ça
auaussi comme défi.
- - Un élément pour chacun d'ene
vovous qu'est-ce que vous allez
susurveiller Sébastien?
- - L'abrogation officielle de
l'l'Assemblée nationale
prprobablement mercredi Monsieua
bebesoin du décret du conseil ds
miministres Rulli mercredi.
- - Un délai des contentieux à
BrBrome-Missisquoi j'ai pas de
SaSavoie le résultat final dans
cecette construction.
- - Merci beaucoup